[Music]
when French mathematician Lawrence Watts
was in high school he started to worry
that he wasn't smart enough to solve
math problems maybe you know a similar
feeling you sit down to take a math test
and you feel your heart beat faster and
your palms start to sweat you get
butterflies in your stomach and you
can't concentrate this phenomenon is
called math anxiety and if it happens to
you you're not alone researchers think
about 20% of the population suffers from
it some psychologists even consider it a
diagnosable condition
but having mathematical anxiety doesn't
necessarily mean you're bad at math not
even close
LaRoche Watts went on to win the Fields
Medal the highest award in mathematics
people might think that they're anxious
about math because they're bad at it but
it's often the other way around they're
doing poorly in math because they're
anxious about it some psychologists
think that's because math anxiety
decreases a cognitive resource called
working memory that's the short-term
memory system that helps you organize
the information you need to complete a
task worrying about being able to solve
math problems or not doing well on a
test eats up working memory leaving less
of it available to tackle the math
itself people can suddenly struggle with
even basic math skills like arithmetic
that they've otherwise mastered
academic anxiety certainly isn't limited
to math but it does seem to happen much
more frequently and cause more harm in
that subject so why would that be
researchers aren't yet sure but some
studies suggest that the way children
are exposed to math by their parents and
teachers play a large part if parents
talk about math like something
challenging and unfamiliar children can
internalize that teachers with math
anxiety are also likely to spread it to
their students pressure to solve
problems quickly it dials up stress even
more and in some cultures being good at
math is a sign of being smart in general
when the stakes are that high it's not
surprising that students are anxious
even Myriam ms irani an influential
mathematician who was the first woman to
win the Fields Medal felt unconfident
and lost interest in mathematics because
her math teacher in middle school didn't
think she was talented so if you
experience mathematical anxiety what can
you do relaxation techniques like short
breathing exercises have improved test
performance and students with math
anxiety writing down your worries can
also help this strategy may give you a
chance to reevaluate
a stressful experience freeing up
working memory and if you have the
chance physical activity like a brisk
walk deepens breathing and helps relieve
muscle tension preventing anxiety from
building you can also use your knowledge
about the brain to change your mindset
the brain is flexible and the areas
involved in math skills can always grow
and develop this is a psychological
principle called the growth mindset
thinking of yourself as someone who can
grow and improve can actually help you
grow and improve if you're a teacher or
parent of young children try being
playful with math and focusing on the
creative aspects that can build the
numerical skills that help students
approach math with confidence later on
importantly you should give children the
time and space to work through their
answers and if you're an administrator
make sure your teachers have the
positive attitudes and mathematical
confidence necessary to inspire
confidence in all of their students
also don't let anyone spread the myth
that boys are innately better than girls
and math that is completely false
if you experience math anxiety it may
not help to just know that math anxiety
exists or perhaps it's reassuring to put
a name to the problem regardless if you
take a look around yourself the odds are
good that you'll see someone
experiencing the same thing as you just
remember that the anxiety is not a
reflection of your ability but it is
something you can concur with time and
awareness
[Music]
you